[Música]
boa tarde a todos senhoras e senhores
vou falar um pouco hoje sobre negociar
seu eu trabalho com negociação trabalho
com resolução de disputas
tive a sorte aí há cerca de 12 anos de
ser admitido no mestrado em harvard e
aprender com alguns dos grandes nomes da
negociação da resolução de disputas
sendo cheguei até uma loja de fish lobby
por do lobby pelo quem estudei o
trabalho de pessoas muito influentes que
todos conhecem o ellure tiver sorte de
estudar e levar muito a sério todo o
trabalho dessas pessoas
voltei para o brasil e comecei a
trabalhar com conflitos bem complexos
com indenizações em catástrofes em
acidentes aéreos situações em que as
emoções das pessoas eram muito
acalorados
continuo trabalhando tragédias
ambientais trabalho com mediação
resseguro brigas de construtoras brigas
de sócio brigas de empreendedores quando
as inovações falham é trabalho com todo
esse tipo de conflito aparentemente
intratável e usando essas técnicas que
aprendi nos meus professores
eu sempre tive um mapa o mapa da mina
com as suas molduras teóricas deles pra
me ajudar a resolver os problemas quando
fui convidado hoje pra fazer essa fala
eu me senti desafiado é eu sempre fui
muito fiel à a tudo que eu estudei agora
é a primeira vez que os obrigado a fazer
um filtro a vir aqui em 15 minutos
explicar qual é o meu filho que eu
enxergo da negociação e 15 minutos qual
o recado que eu quero dar pra ajudar as
pessoas a negociar melhor e eu acho que
assim eu me pego que eu faço o dia
inteiro e o embrulho mensagens eu pego
uma mensagem de uma pessoa coloca umbro
de uma embalagem nela e mandou pra outra
o quando eu quero passar uma mensagem
para convencer alguém a fazer alguma
coisa por mim
eu fico pensando como que o embrulho é
como eu coloco essa mensagem que eu
pensei o que eu queria
a coisa mais importante que eu tenho
para falar sobre a negociação o grande
recado que eu tenho para falar é como
você pode embrulhar sua mensagem é dar
um pequeno manual de de como você em
breve a sua mensagem do pequeno ou
grande se tem um grande problema que
você quer negociar que se precisa
cumprir seu objetivo se tem uma pequena
situação que você quer que alguém faz o
que quer com o caminho pra você olhar
bem a sua mensagem
nessa pequena teoria que eu desenvolvi
eu separei cinco grandes elementos pra
você se concientizar pra você ter um
pouco mais de lucidez de como você deve
emoldurar a empacotar as suas mensagens
o primeiro foco é basicamente uma
discussão em uma negociação você tem
três focos
o primeiro é o foco da força o foco do
poder militar o que eu quero em ninguém
vai sair machucado
esse enfoque ele é problemático porque
existe uma regra de ouro na negociação
que a regra da reciprocidade
quando você faz uma coisa outra hora vai
imitar vai fazer igual então como se a
ameaça do outro lado vai também ameaça o
conflito pode escalá perigoso
o segundo foco é o foco vamos assim de
provar que você tá certo o direito das
regras
então vou pra usar uma moldura que vou
tentar convencer o outro lado que eu
estou certo
esse daí também falha porque você
raramente sede para um argumento quando
uma pessoa argumenta você argumenta de
volta
você não vai sair você tá certo deixa eu
te dar o que você quer ser o momento é
de volta muitas vezes escala você vai
precisar de um terceiro para decidir
é difícil nesse nesse meio vou convencer
o outro lado o terceiro método
o terceiro foco que eu proponho para
você construir as suas molduras é
convencer o outro lado a atirar o que
você quer
não parece muito melhor e ainda proponho
mais convencer o outro lado a te dar o
que você quer
feliz sorrindo como é que você faz isso
então essa teoria da moldura começa por
esse foco
mas isso é muito difícil porque porque
às vezes é outra pessoa que está
negociando é alguém que você não tem uma
boa relação você não está num bom
momento com ela pode ser aquele seu
sócio que você tem uma mágoa que você já
não aguenta mais
pode ser que seu vizinho barulhento
aquele seu fornecedor que acabou de
descumpriu o contrato ainda quer receber
pode ser que você tem um problema de
telefonia a judith ali do outro lado da
linha a ideia pessoal é que você consiga
mesmo com essas pessoas quanto mais é
difícil se elas forem mais ainda é uma
oportunidade de você construiu uma uma
embalagem de uma maneira que você
consiga o que você quer
eu costumo olhar todas essas pessoas
como a galinha dos ovos de ouro
é uma idéia sim do foco no meu objetivo
foco no resultado e não quero provar que
eu estou certo e não quero provar que
sou mais forte eu quero o meu resultado
eu quero o ovo se vai pegar o ovo da
galinha se vai bater na cabeça da
galinha
você vai matar a galinha você vai pegar
uma vez na próxima semana vai ficar
você vai ficar discutindo com a galinha
não se vai proximar botar uma comidinha
fazer um carinho e pegar o ovo pra você
então a ideia pessoal do foco é você
conseguir entender que o seu objetivo é
falar montar a sua mensagem usar
escolher as palavras de uma maneira que
você faça outro lado de seguir não é um
primeiro insight que eu queria colocar
mais pessoal o segundo a segunda
variável é você
você precisa ter um pouco de
autopercepção weah e é que palavras
cabem na sua boca né
a gente sabe que dependendo do seu
status no empresa dependendo sua
expertise aquilo que você fala convence
mais as pessoas atinge mais as pessoas
mas é complicado mesmo que você seja o
dono da empresa o presidente se você
confia muito só no seu status ou numa
suposta expertise você não toma muito
cuidado como você coloca as coisas
isso pode te buscar depois de trazer
problemas
e se você ainda não tem o status que
você gostaria
dentro da organização e tenho certeza
que se você for usando melhores
embalagens melhores molduras com as
pessoas para conseguir suas coisas você
vai rapidamente subir também tem uma
questão de características pessoais
se você é um pitbull fortão é com aquela
orelhinha de repolho aquele cara
assustador
talvez você sabe que você vai ter que
ter talvez sorri mais né talvez é ser
mais caloroso escolher melhor as
palavras eu por exemplo sei que eu tenho
um perfil mais suave uma voz mais suave
às vezes eu posso me aventurar num
recado mais duro tem uma carinha de bebê
posso dar um recado mais duro que eu vou
ter um impacto é menor então às vezes
até abusa um pouco disso um dia ainda
vou me ferrar mas sim em dado certo é a
sua característica pessoal também é
importante mas o grande recado que eu
queria dar sobre você é a sua reputação
a sua reputação vai ajudar muito na
força da sua palavra da sua moldura você
tem que buscar a reputação por dois
motivos por honestidade por competência
se você melhora sua reputação nesses
dois sentidos das palavras que saem da
sua boca vão ter mais poder
a gente sabe todo bom negociador sabe
que quando você que a confiança pode ser
resgatada quando se está numa situação
de desconfiança você pode resgatar se
você tentar passar uma mensagem pra
alguém se faz ela perfeito pessoa vai
olhar pra você falar onde está a
pegadinha
acho que é uma dica pra você olhar desce
se a sua reputação se você atinge essa
pessoa do jeito que você realmente
atingir
você precisa entender talvez o que
aconteceu porque ela desconfia de você
que você pode fazer para melhorar pra
tornar essa pessoa para resgatar essa
confiança é perfeitamente resgatável o
terceiro
o ponto que eu gostaria de colocar eu
acho que o mais importante é a empatia
que empatia é a capacidade de você se
colocar na pele de outra pessoa mas mais
do que isso é a capacidade de você
demonstrar isso de você colocar isso na
sua fala que é é é acho que sim
se você não atender a outra pessoa ela
nunca vai concordar com você nunca vai
ceder pra você
se você não atender aos interesses dela
se você não entender as pressões que ela
tem que ela está sofrendo
se você não entender que informação
falta pra ela que você pode dar para ela
para destravá ela e se você não ajuda a
ela a dar um passo para trás e e
encaminhar o sentido que você quer
vou dar um exemplo um dia desses numa
reunião eu tive a reunião terminou antes
estava super cansado resolvi antecipar
meu volte a antecipar dois gols foi o
meu cansaço ali acabei errando
alterei duas vezes o mesmo vôo e não
teria outra uma grande besteira ligas
tema um dinheiro ali na internet mudando
passagem no concelho meu problema
liguei pra empresa aérea para reclamar
porque eu fiz aqui um negócio um
passageiro frequente da pcm ajudar quem
não pagar isso tantas vezes
aí o atendente foi foi implacável comigo
foi duro não foi o senhor refaça aí a
passagem não tenho nada a ver com isso
conversas calor mas que absurdo conversa
realmente escalou ficou quente trocamos
algumas elegância sally acontece com
todo mundo e e um certo momento é eu
parti para a próxima estratégia na
teoria da negociação que é troque os
jogadores para aquela velha história por
favor me chama se o supervisor não vou
chamar chamas por isso não vou chamar
assim ninguém vai resolver o problema em
seu total
aí eu tive uma ideia virei para ele e
falei olha vamos fazer um acordo aqui te
propor um acordo se chama seu supervisor
eu não vou contar nada para ele sobre
essa conversa que a gente teve e ainda
vou te avaliar bem quando terminar o
atendimento pode ser
ele não disse meshaal já a renovação de
supervisor em dois minutos eu conversei
com ele e com o supervisor ele não me
devolver o dinheiro mas me deu um bônus
para a próxima compra fiquei feliz em
resolver o problema pessoal isso é uma
técnica que o uso que é assim quando
você toma uma situação adversa que eu
tento fazer entrar na cabeça daquela
pessoa por um milésimo de segundo e
pensar se eu fosse ela porque eu teria
me comportando assim porque porque eu
diria isso porque eu gravaria isso tem
um volto pra minha cabeça no milésimo de
segundo e digo algo que vai travar ela
que o que ela precisa ouvir para
destravá isso funciona bastante
em casos mais complexos que você não
consegue se chama arte você vai
acordando pra isso você vai começar a
fazer cada vez mais rápido em situações
que você precisa um pouco mais de
informação então você não entendeu
direito qual é o problema da pessoa e
você pergunta faz pergunta te entender
qual o seu problema que está acontecendo
às vezes você consegue primeiro
perguntar principalmente sobre os
interesses necessidades e preocupações
sobre as pressões para quem ele tem que
atender para você conseguir montar sua
história de uma maneira que você
comunica que isso bem
a empatia é a coisa mais importante você
não atender outro lado se você não
considerar o problema dele
se você não ajudar a pessoa a a abrir o
caminho para destravá você não vai
conseguir
o próximo item diria que a quarta
variável importante que você tem que ter
lógica é fundamento a negociar seu você
não tá aqui pra aguentar sim pessoal
quando pus quando necessário você tem
que saber argumentar e você tem que ter
lógica o que eu diria é que a sua um
balázio em na sua moldura tem que parar
de pé tem que fazer sentido
você tem que usar critérios
independentes práticas de mercado como
os tribunais julgam se for uma questão
jurídica como as pessoas se comportam
que uma grande
forma de persuasão que aprova social que
todo mundo está fazendo deve ser bom
comportamento esperado das pessoas
você tem que ter lógica você toma muito
cuidado quando você for uma negociação
colocar um argumento usar uma metáfora
ao ou colocar uma situação que você pode
deixar margem para contra-argumentar eu
lembro de um caso que estava mediando
uma questão de resseguro rompimento de
uma esteira que carregava minério e eu
estava em uma reunião com o grupo de
resseguradores ingleses a indústria
brasileira e e em inglês foi dizer olha
cíntia como eu vejo situação é como você
comprar um carro usar o carro por anos
não trocar o pneu
aí o pneu história você bate vai cobrar
do seguro
essa foi a a metáfora da embalagem que
ele deu nessa nesse argumento o outro
lado fumagina eu comprei uma bmw na
melhor loja mais cara e depois de seis
meses o pneu estourou
então você tem que pagar e começou o
ataque naquela colocação gerou o
contra-golpe tudo e aí a coisa esse
calor piorou bem a situação tudo o que
você fala numa numa numa negociar seu
tem que parar de pé tem que parar de pé
tem que ter lógica você tem que
justificar cada idéia é que cada
proposta tem que ter uma história forte
por trás quando você pensa história por
trás quando você pensa possíveis contra
argumentos quando você é linda ela você
fecha é que nem quando se escreve um
trabalho acadêmico você tem que testar
essa hipótese
a lógica é é fundamental
o último item que eu colocaria é o
processo
essa história de criar suas as suas
molduras das suas embalagens é um
processo se você tem tempo cria pensa
ela testa ensaia testa com pessoas se
tem uma negociação importante como isso
vai soar o sino é uma situação de
bate-pronto como algumas que eu escrevi
aqui testes sua hipótese se prepare
em programas de indenização de vítimas
são reuniões que a gente consegue mais
ou menos prevê quais são os tópicos que
vão ser discutidos e preparo toda a
equipe todas as molduras de todas as
discussões possíveis que podem surgir e
isso é muito bom porque prepara é
preparar todos eles sabem responder
inclusive a ordem em que você fala as
coisas né porque a essa é uma construção
também lógica ordem que você coloca as
coisas vai assim poupando energia mental
das pessoas você vai colocando cada
pedaço de informação necessária para que
você consiga fazer a pessoa entender o
que você quer
a preparação é muito boa só que você
também tem que ter flexibilidade você
também tem que tocar de ouvido vamos
dizer assim eu lembro também uma dessas
recentes é mediações que estava
participando com agricultores que a
gente tinha que explicar pra ele que os
critérios de indenização eram legítimos
então a moldura tóxica né embalagem que
nós usávamos usamos é olha todos esses
critérios foram aprovados por comissões
no governo foram levados pelo governo
foram aprovados
e aí o senhor agricultor virou pra mim
governo tudo bandido caiu um avião aí um
a menos e assim pude sair dessa e japão
mas também tiveram as reuniões com as
comunidades aqui que o senhor só
participou a gente debater com as
comunidades comunidades aprovaram também
os parentes não se às vezes você tem uma
estratégia estratégia falha se tem que
cair de pé faz parte e você também tem
que procurar outro caminho então mesmo
com muito preparo se tem que ter a
adaptabilidade e flexibilidade ler
situação mas às vezes você leu errado
tem que enfim como a capoeira é você cai
mas continua xingando e e segue o e após
o processo vamos ver preparação
flexibilidade durante é sempre bom você
ter esse momento de avaliar seu como o
que eu proponho aqui é uma arte é você
cada vez melhorar sua a sua construção
você como construtor dessas
lages você embalar melhor as suas
palavras é legal você avaliar o que deu
certo eo que deu errado e registrando e
aumentando o seu repertório ao longo da
sua vida então eu acho que sim a
primeiros 15 minutos o que eu acho mais
irrelevante como você passa as suas
mensagens com as diretrizes não é pra
você conseguir embalar suas mensagens é
o foco foco em fazer outro lado vim com
você é é é a empatia é você lembrar que
o outro lado se você não atendeu ao
interesse do outro lado você não vai
conseguir o que você quer é a lógica é
saber que o que você fala tem que parar
de pé é você saber que aquelas palavras
têm que caber na sua boca que que você
tem que se preocupar com a sua reputação
e é um processo constante
espero que essas idéias não têm vocês aí
nas suas negociações
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]